for months Israel has been divided by
prime minister Benyamin netanyahu's
attempts to weaken the
Judiciary but as the country faces war
with Hamas some of those differences
have been set aside Netanyahu has formed
a Unity government and for the time
being sidelined the far-right players in
his
Coalition but after the war will that
help him remain in
office
I think you should certainly never count
netan out uh that is something that we
have all learned over the past decade
and a half but I do think it is hard to
see how he emerges from this politically
we've seen some very striking scenes
over the past few days something that a
lot of Israelis have been pointing out
is that the Israeli government has been
almost invisible since Saturday
ministers you would expect them to be
visiting hospitals uh visiting the
wounded visiting people who can't return
to their homes because their homes were
destroyed uh but there hasn't been much
of that happening and and we know why
because the handful of ministerial
visits that have taken place uh we've
seen very angry videos of of ordinary
Israelis shouting down members of this
government there is just tremendous
public anger not just at netan himself
but also at the government I've heard
this in talking to Israelis uh you've
had people who are right-wing people who
are religious in Israel who have noticed
over the past few days that the people
being called up to serve in the Army now
uh the people who rushed on Saturday to
try and free besiege kibuts in southern
Israel and helped survivors of the
massacre some of them were left-wingers
and so this idea that Netanyahu has
pushed for many many years that the
Israeli left is unpatriotic and and it
undermines Israel's security I think
people have realized that that might not
be true over the past few days netan
will try and do what he always does
which is shift the blame to some some
else he will blame the generals and the
Spy Chiefs for an intelligence failure
and certainly they deserve some of the
blame and and I am sure there'll be a
commission of inquiry that looks into
what went wrong but I don't think it's
going to work this time I don't think
netan is going to be able to shift all
the blame away from himself any positive
change would start with new political
leadership on both sides um I think
there is a bit of optimism that this
will move Israeli politics in a more
Centrist Direction and that would be a
good thing for an Israel that has been
torn apart by uh political tumult over
the past
year